والسويد
الوعد
تسليم 73 إرهابيا لتركيا حزب العمال الكردستاني و
عنصر مع جمع التبرعات للتمديدات
حظر أنشطة التوظيف و
تحقيقهم
ترتيب الاتفاقية الموقعة
حساسيات تركيا
كدليل على التفاهم
نحن نرى بالطبع هذه البداية
إنها دعوة ، الشيء الرئيسي هو وعودك
التنفيذ المقبل
المسائل المسجلة في المذكرة في هذه العملية.
سوف تتبع تنفيذه بدقة و O
سوف نلقي باللون الأحمر وفقًا لذلك
اشترك
هذه
إلى usda bina und Database الطريق إلى
حقل
للانضمام إلى ney إلى TOKİ William friedkin
الجو
الجولة 3
هو
بادئ ذي بدء ، كان هذا PKK wifi PC piva.
فيتو ، تم حذف هذه المنظمات الإرهابية و
يجب التخلص منه ، إنه قانوني بشأنهم
إنهاء الترتيبات في أقرب وقت ممكن.
مطلوب
مما لا شك فيه أن هذا مختار تركيا و
مفاوضات صعبة لأمتنا
بعد العملية الدبلوماسية
انتصار نقوم به من على كتف البرلمان
لن تعمل هذه الوظيفة بعد أن تقوم بها على أي حال.
تقع على السويد وفنلندا من قبل
واجباتهم للوفاء
أحتاج هذا بالفعل في النص
يأخذون مكانهم
ماذا نفعل إذا استوفوا
نقوم بذلك نرسله إلى كتف البرلمان
ولكن إذا لم يتم الوفاء بها
طبعا البرلمان كتفا الى كتف ووعد والدته
ليس الموضوع